new bombshell documents detailing
alleged sexual abuse by jeffrey
epstein's former girlfriend galaine
maxwell
the unsealed records are from a 2015
lawsuit filed by virginia roberts
guffrey against maxwell
they claim maxwell abused many young
girls on epstein's private island
the documents also mention bill clinton
guffrey says she saw the former
president on epstein's island with
maxwell
and quote two young girls
but did not accuse him of any wrongdoing
a spokesperson
for clinton says it's a lie and he has
never been to the island all right just
before we get to everything we have a
fact check for juan usa today did the
obama administration deplete the federal
stockpile of n95 masks
fact check true also washington state
and oregon have both out
in cases all right so juan i want to ask
you about bill clinton because this
isn't just
jesse no wait a second jesse you say
things like that and then you just run
on like it's true
jesse you didn't see a spike in the 14
days after the process
and guess what and guess what no i'm
just telling that's the truth no spike
in those steps
after those big protests and then second
you can look it up
there was a tremendous preparation by
the obama administration made available
to the trump administration
you were wrong all right so bill clinton
on epstein island
allegedly being accused of a sex
trafficking victim being on epstein
island
he denies it it's the second person that
fingers him as
being there does that concern
you
concern me well i think that a lot of
people have to answer questions about
what happened
with jeffrey epstein including two
presidents but in the clinton case
i just recently watched that netflix uh
documentary and
they have somebody who was there who
says he saw clinton
on that island so i think it's it's not
just
clinton it's not just trump i think a
lot of people
including a lot of the law enforcement
the prosecutors in florida i think they
have a lot
a lot to answer for now i will say this
on a positive note jesse
that i think that this discovery process
and the prosecution
is hopefully a step in the direction of
giving the victims
some sense of justice because i think as
we get involved with all the gossip
about the celebrities and the powerful
elite men
who avoid justice we shouldn't lose
focus on these young women who were
abused
i agree with that that's the most
important thing all right greg what do
you think of the new revelations from
the deposition
well first of all i would like to
apologize for saying that dana's sweater
looked like an ad for fruit stripe gum
it's actually the sweater that marsha
brady wore
boy when she ran against greg brady for
student body president
all right so did she wait let's talk
about bill clinton by the way
i'm sorry i think she i think she went
or it was a tie i can't remember
but let's stick to the facts okay let's
stick to the facts dana
and the fact is trump was never on this
island so i don't know why
juan keeps bringing up trump but that's
that's fine so bill clinton
claims he was not on the island but he's
identified as being there
and if there's one thing we know about
bill clinton he never
ever lies about sex so i think we can
trust him
now the question is if you ask bill
clinton
is bill clinton guilty he's going to say
it depends on what your definition of
is is and here's where you get to the
point
you can't spell island without is
no greg that is some airtight legal
jujitsu right there emily um thank you
this is a this is a discovery process
that i think is just
in the beginning as more and more
records are unsealed a lot of redactions
in this deposition um what do you make
of
today's news i would like to clarify
for viewers that this is from discovery
and depositions
from a 2018 defamation case by virginia
du frey
against galen maxwell right she came out
publicly and essentially said glenn
maxwell
by by shaming me in public you have
defamed me so this is all from that so
this isn't
new this is just new to us it's also
from the investigation
by federal investigators in the 2008
mild plea result from that federal
investigation in florida
so what we're seeing now is the fruits
of the judge and that in that case
saying it's public interest to see all
of this information
galain's team tried real hard to keep
this under wraps
they also are arguing and trying for the
release
the public release of all of the victims
names which should serve which should
serve no public purpose
other than for them to continue
embarking on this victim-shaming
ordeal so i'd like viewers to keep that
all in mind because this oh and by the
way a lot of that
is what the current investigation that
resulted in criminal charges
was based on so it's not like this is
new now it's just new to
us but it's all troubling and remember
power
is money we should all care regardless
of party about taking down anyone who
participated in an international sex
trafficking ring
yeah we should follow the truth wherever
it leads dana i mean marcia
dana perino finish this segment up
i gotta say i thought fruit stripe gum
was was excellent marcia brady even
better i hope he has something
planned for the next round i would just
mention one thing
even though this is from 2018 it did
give us some new information
or a contradiction recently glenn
maxwell had said
it had been over a decade since she had
spoken to epstein
in this in these documents that were
revealed there's an email between
maxwell and epstein from 2015. so
the prosecutors perhaps knowing that
that was there
and then going in to arrest her
knew that they had something so perhaps
having caught her
possibly in a lie she'll be more likely
to cooperate
all right